the spirit award for best first
screenplay goes to
okay
michael cernovsky
vanessa block
this is the first nomination and first
win for michael sarnoski and vanessa
block the two met his classmates at yale
university
sarnoski also made his directorial debut
with this film
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
uh that's really cool um it's been
amazing to see
how after a couple years of a lot of
grief and isolation this film that's
kind of about isolation and connection
has connected with a lot of people um
and yeah i just want to thank film
independent i want to thank neon
all of portland
uh
portland's film scene and the restaurant
scene our incredible actors for bringing
the script to life nick cage and alex
wolf and adam arkin uh
i'm so nervous this is you were there a
lot of you guys there's a lot of faces
but yeah and my manager michael diamond
my mom who i love very much i mean i
just we couldn't have done this without
just a whole family of people supporting
us uh pulse and ai and dimitri chingu
and
who am i forgetting what no i just we're
all trying to be stylish and i think
we're walking out of here with
hypothermia is anybody else freezing
cold i'm so cold
oh my god uh please turn up the heat no
uh tom tom quinn at neon thank you so
much the entire team at neon an amazing
company
for believing in our project and
championing incredible material just an
amazing place we've we've become family
my producing partner dmitrit singhu
sitting right over there many congrats
thank you for being in the trenches with
us on this film when no one else
believed in it i think it's so important
to champion smaller films many of us
have been again working in the trenches
just kind of tirelessly trying to get
something off the ground and that's the
beauty of independent cinema is that we
don't necessarily have all of the
resources and often our voices are sort
of disenfranchised in a way and i think
that being given this platform an
opportunity to speak up tell our stories
challenge audiences is so critically
important so thank you all
honored privileged
freezing cold but happy
and uh
my mom mama melanie block steven vlog
and my sister jenna block this is for
you you guys believed in me when uh when
you know no one else did they believed
in us and so we love you and this is for
you thank you thank you
you